let me start with you Michael the Apple
watch is it the iPad no because my pod
no it's it's really neither what it is
is it's it's an accessory and because it
still requires one of these it still
requires that you have a phone in your
pocket and an iphone and so I think
there are a lot of people that are gonna
buy them Apple estimates about 17
million people will will buy one but i'm
not sure everyone's gonna use it and
there's a lot of useful things to do
with it but it's not gonna be a habit
okay Brian Kelly you're in the cutting
edge of use of this stuff is it actually
a toy or can you use it to get the room
for 12 bucks yeah you can definitely use
it for you know for travel especially
you know going through the TSA you can
actually have your boarding pass so
instead of having your phone check you
can actually be connected you know when
your flight changes you can get a
notification on your wrists you know
quicker than on your phone so when but I
think it you bet air but Tom I through
the Apple watch maybe for travel I care
that I won't have to take my in a
meeting you don't have to take your
phone out of your pocket could see okay
you've got an email from but this is I
mean this is this is key to to Olivia's
point Michael Wolff um you know I've
read some lukewarm appraisals of the
watch and they consistently say it has
to be linked to your phone in your
pocket you got to carry your phone with
you you can't just go out with the watch
when that link is severed will the watch
become a bigger deal it's not clear
because if you look at it the world has
been moving to bigger screens not
smaller ones look at the size of the
iphone it got bigger a lot of that
driven by the Samsung phones and so
we're not sure whether or not something
that's on your wrist is really going to
take the place of that larger screen I
mean yes there's a lot of support from
the tech community Apple's announced
that there are 3,000 apps that will wit
that will be available on launch but
that doesn't necessarily mean it's going
to become central to people's lives I do
agree there's gonna be lots of
applications for it I think the fitness
aspect of it is what I'm excited also i
had a Fitbit it actually tells you how
much you sleep how well you sleep how
much you've been walking so especially
when you're traveling time zones and
everything it's important to keep track
of how much fancy guy we don't want to
know
I wanna think about it less yeah they
know I don't wanna be reminded of how
little I'm sleepiness total you don't
want it to do share it on Facebook yes
sir I give us an update on what you
essentially invented what use was
analysis of all these credit cards are
we ready for a new round of points wars
with the bank's wears them does Jamie
Dimon hate you as much as she does she's
kidding me his products have you know
gotten what you know that the credit
card companies are making billions are
doing great city is the newest one on
the market with new products and they
are really everyone's nipping at amex
right yeah and the the competition right
now is out of control city just upped
all their signup bonuses on their key
products to 50,000 points which if you
know how to use them as a thousand bucks
think about a thousand bucks for getting
a singular thousand dollar gift
basically yeah if you transfer to their
transfer partners and know how to
leverage it but yeah points guy you
aren't allowed to confuse me last time
you're on you said I had to get a
starwood card and I was working on that
now car what about it the beauty of it
all is that you can have multiple it's
like stocks would you ever just invest
in one stock know you want to diversify
crisis pay them off on time you can beat
the system for our audience and I want
to go to something we just covered
recently which is Olivia's going to 14
weddings this year what is your advice
to the young cranny that's like
nothing's yeah I'm trying to stay so
especially if I mean there's so many
different frequent flyer perks like
Southwest has a companion pass that you
can get from getting basically two
credit cards and it allows you for two
years to have a free companion travel
wherever you go even if you use points
it's one of the most incredible perks
out there so it's finding the right
program for you of course Southwest
isn't great if you're going to be going
to 12 weddings in Europe but if you're
gonna go across the u.s. what's your
advice to Michael Wolfe you got a hitter
he's a points expert we were just
talking about it but yeah I mean it's
just I always say get flexible points
City thank you american express
membership rewards that have multiple
options so no matter if you want to know
the maldives or topeka you have options
you know we have another some in a while
but i just pulled a quote of the day
from you re credit cards if you pay them
off on time you can be a system well dub
nobody does that i I do oh my god i have
about 25 credit that's absurd Lord but
my fight goes and high 700's I have a
mortgage you know the biggest factor of
your credit is
how much you put 785 but it's how much
you pay on time and your debt to credit
ratio so I've all these credit cards at
a zero balance it's more you have i've
been getting a mortgage and they said i
don't have enough credit cards because I
don't know lon I like it that way though
I have three credit cards Michael Pat 55
Brendan I have more children than I have
credit cards gower the jar meant to my
kids okay Olivia we won't ask where are
you going this weekend nowhere nowhere
then that's a brick such a surveillance
breaks closer right there Olivia Sterns
on the island of Manhattan yep there's
gonna be wild